[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pat 40 sports illustrated senior writer
he's going to the wisconsin notre dame
game on saturday he was at cincinnati
indiana last week figured we'd have him
on get an update because the college
football playoff committee
met yesterday but did not vote
to
expand to 12 teams
pat joins us now
can you tell me why they didn't vote
uh pettiness
jealousy rivalry distrust
short-sightedness i guess that would be
the the short list of reasons
uh
basically it comes down to
a
a unwillingness to
i think let
uh the the sec and espn get everything
at once here uh more than anything else
it's like okay greg sankey was on this
committee that helped
come up with with expanding the playoff
to 12.
it would be a huge financial gain espn
would be the benefactor the sole media
benefactor and we don't like what
happened with expansion with texas and
oklahoma so we're going to
throw
a stick into the wheels here and at
least slow it down i still think we will
get to expansion i don't know that it's
going to be 8. i don't know it's going
to be 12 but we're going to get to
expansion with multiple broadcast
partners is my belief but we still have
to wait a few years for this contract to
expire
right yeah now you know i mean they they
could
get into this probably and open this up
and do something by like 2024 if
everyone wanted to but this is part of
the the slowdown process is
uh we are not going to
do this the way
certain people want it we're getting
like if you're the big ten the pac-12
and the acc you're saying okay well this
is not just going to be everything the
way the sec wants you brought up uh the
number eight i was told don't be locked
into 12 because it might start with baby
steps to eight and might even jump to 16
and might blow right past 12. what are
you hearing about down the road
well i certainly think the all the
numbers are still on the table um you
know i think 16 is a tough sell right
now from what i heard just from people
coming out of there
worried about number of games played and
how deep into january you're going to go
with this thing uh that there is a
feeling that that
it would be a rare thing for a team to
play 17 games it could happen
but if you're at 16 a 16 team playoff
it's almost certain that somebody's
going to play 17 games uh whereas it
would be unlikely otherwise they want to
keep this thing at 16 or fewer games for
the most part is they're trying to sell
this as as relative amateur sports
which segues into name image and
likeness here we are a couple of weeks
into the season is name image and
likeness working
yeah i think it is i think it's working
quite well uh you know i mean i think i
know this for all the people that sat
out there and said uh this is gonna ruin
the sport you know this is gonna turn
into pro football i already watched pro
football i'm not gonna watch the ratings
are huge the ratings have been
phenomenal so far this year uh players
are getting things but have you seen any
sign that it has ruined their product
ruined their work ethic turned them into
you know lazy uh money-grubbing player
no i i haven't seen that uh you've seen
non-revenue sport athletes make money
off of it i i i don't think that there
has been anything that i've seen that
says this was a bad idea i mentioned
this in the first hour of the show that
uh you know james franklin beating
auburn at home sort of keeps him at the
top of the usc list there's obviously
mutual interest but he's either going to
get a huge pay raise at penn state or
he's going to get a huge pay raise going
to usc
and then i was also told make no mistake
about it every coach wants to be
mentioned for this job whether they want
it or not
they want to get a pay rate like their
agents love this like privately the
coaches are like did i get mentioned yes
you did awesome now go now go to the
press conference and act like you have
no interest in going to usc what do you
think how do you think this plays out
well you're 100 right about that and
that's one thing usc did do by doing
this at this point in the year you just
gave two months of leverage to the
agents for these guys and so
uh you know i they're gonna do their
work behind the scenes if they want to
get you know in front of chris peterson
or bob stoops who's not coaching right
now they can but everybody else has got
to play coy
uh as you said be interested while
acting like they're not interested
james franklin and luke fickle i think
are sitting in good positions here you
know i think franklin
uh would fit very well at usc fickle
would be a little bit tougher fit and he
also worked with mike bohn at cincinnati
and i'm not sure he is super anxious to
work with mike bone again uh i'm not
saying that a bad relationship but i'm
not sure they had a great relationship
yeah
i was told he didn't want to leave the
midwest now that could mean a lot of
different things but uh i was told he
fickle didn't want to leave the midwest
he's a midwest guy through and through i
mean that has been him he's pretty happy
at cincinnati and now cincinnati has you
know putative
power five membership coming with the
big 12 if the big 12 can kind of hold on
to that uh status
i i just don't think he's the kind of
guy that that ever in his professional
life thought gosh it'd be great to coach
at usc whereas a lot of other guys i'm
sure thought that he's pat 40 sports
illustrated senior writer he'll be at
the wisconsin notre dame game
game is bigger for who notre dame or
wisconsin
well it's bigger for notre dame because
they're still undefeated
and they've proved nothing they really
haven't played very well so far they're
3-0 but it's an unimpressive 3-0
uh this is a chance to to beat a pretty
good team
and maybe get yourself uh playing on a
higher level and get people to take you
a little more seriously as a as a
national uh playoff contender uh the
problem notre dame's schedule dan is
tricky it's not just that the games the
who they're playing but when they play
so many teams coming off of bye weeks
that they they are at a by disadvantage
this is one of them and they're going to
keep running into that cincinnati next
week goes off of an open date into south
bend and there are several others
throughout the season just
wear and tear and preparation time notre
dame's at the disadvantage five
different times this uh this season most
disappointing team so far is who
oh boy uh i would have to say
really i'd say ohio state i just i you
know i i thought that they were i i
bought into the belief that they would
plug and play with these you know young
guys coming in and everything would just
keep running smoothly and that does that
they lost at home to oregon but they
were pretty well outplayed in that game
and then you know to come back and be
2120 against a tulsa team that lost to
an fcs team i'm like what what is wrong
there there's just something that's not
clicking that i really didn't expect
i would nominate clemson but yeah maybe
i overrated clemson but dju has not been
trevor lawrence uh 2.0
that offense uh
that surprises me a little bit are they
still no class of the acc but are they a
top 10 team in your opinion
no they're not in my top 10 as of now uh
they're not you know that i mean the the
grim struggle against georgia tech uh
saturday well that was that was really
wild to see them
struggle to score 14 and barely hold off
georgia tech at home so they've got
issues what they've got also was an easy
schedule they could end up being 11-1
and not be very good
what happens if lane kiffin beats nick
saban
[Laughter]
the earth splits open
and and like
you know like demons come out i mean now
it would just be
uh it would be incredibly interesting i
mean lane kiffin is a provocateur he's
been an eddie haskell type for those old
enough to know who that is uh you know
he's he he's a guy that loves being a
needler a fly in the ointment and this
would be the ultimate you know sticking
it to the sec establishment to the guy
that fired him as offensive coordinator
in the middle of a playoff they're gonna
have a chance i think i mean they're a
dangerous team they're they're better
defensively and they're really good on
offense
safe travels is always great to catch up
with you again pat thank you
my pleasure dan thank you that's pat 40.
sports illustrated